[Music]
i want to welcome you here
to the national institutes of health as
you know my name is dr lynn holden i'm
actually an emergency medicine physician
how many people have been to the
emergency department
for one thing science day is a way for
students from underrepresented
backgrounds
to come into the wonderful world of the
national institutes of health
and to see firsthand how science is
actually impacting their everyday life
it's a great way for us to build on our
commitment to engagement
trying to to reach out to different
communities students
bring them into science and medicine and
tell them about
scientific careers but also make them
aware of the resources we have that can
help them
in that journey it isn't just about
cells and molecules in biology and
physiology
it's also about social issues and social
justice
and place and behavior and environment
and all these things interact in a
complicated
way i've seen a lot of interesting
scientists
coming from you know families i can't
afford certain things so
and i think that's really inspirational
somehow you know just to be able to see
other people
make their way people who look like me
who don't look like me
today i basically learned what how hard
i have to work to get to where i want to
be
and um first of all like taking college
seriously
saying hearing other other people's
stories and seeing
where they how far they came just
inspired me to
want to push harder i know i've
struggled with
trying to figure out what i want to do
in life as my senior year
but i feel as though everyone has been
given like some great
some really encouraging words as to do
what you're passionate about and
that's what i mean have goals
have dreams embrace yourself back
embrace your mistakes yes my mistakes
has made me who i am to be it doesn't
matter
your background what matters most is
your passion
your determination that is what is going
to make you
reach the top
you